[Music]
hugo joins us in dallas texas hugo
welcome to the ramsay show
hi george hey
what's going on
um so i had a question uh in regards to
the car market right now
um i've been looking for a car for about
six six seven months now
um and i haven't had like much luck for
it um i am a firm believer in uh
not taking uh any loans for for a car
payment at the dealership um i have cash
uh saved up for a car i just don't know
if i should wait uh until the car market
goes down a little bit or if it's the
right time to to buy a car
how much do you have save for the car
uh i have about 8 or 9k
okay
and are you out of debt with a fully
funded emergency fund
um yes i have no debt uh and i have a
thousand for uh emergency fund
okay so we're in baby step three right
now
correct you gotta save up the three to
six months of expenses
what's going on with your car that's
that's causing this urgency to get a new
one
um so the car i i had before the
transmission one now uh it's an it's an
o4 acura so um if i fix the transmission
it's probably like another 2k so 2k is
pretty much what the car is kind of
worth it does have a high mileage right
now
so um i don't want to really fix the car
right now in the rest of the
transmission
um so i'm really just looking forward
for a new car here now
okay so could you sell this thing right
now how much would you get for it about
2k with the transmission being busted
um i would say if if anything maybe like
1k
i can try in this market you could
probably sell it for parts more than
that things are crazy out there right
now
i would do some research i mean you're
you're not in a terrible place because
you don't have debt and so there's not a
lot of desperation here but can you you
can't drive right now right
uh no i can't i
i um i borrow my dad's car for school
land work right now so
it's kind of
i am kind of in a tight spot but i don't
want to lose my head and get a car
payment loan
because i've i've been watching the rams
show for three years now so i know
everything
we teach about
cool well do you know what kind of car
you're looking to get for eight or nine
k
uh yeah um so i'm looking either toyota
or honda and then just the luxury
versions of those which would be the
lexus and the acura
okay
yeah i mean with eight or nine i'm
probably going to go with the honda
toyota because if you're going lexus or
acura you're going to end up where you
were when where you have a luxury car
that is more expensive to maintain and
i'm a big fan those are the only four
brands i love in that space uh because
of the reliability
but i still would be looking at
something cheaper right now especially
as you try to build this emergency fund
because right now if you had an
emergency you'd be screwed
even though you're out of debt
and um i don't know this is a factor too
um
all the cars i've looked at have rebuilt
and salvage titles so i don't know if
that's also i wouldn't do that
okay unless you're a mechanic i wouldn't
be buying a car that has a rebuilt or
savage title there's too much
that we don't know about what happened
and frame damage and if it's safe to
drive and what could go wrong with it so
if i'm you i'm not going to a dealership
because you're not going to get a deal
at a dealership right now they're all
going to charge you over msrp when they
find out you're paying cash they're
going to charge you even more because
they're not making money off the deal
versus financing so if i'm you i'm going
to facebook marketplace i'm going to
craigslist and i'm going to someone
saying hey you have it listed for 10
i'll give you 8 500 cash today
and you commit and you show up and you
get it make sure you whatever you look
at you get it inspected by a mechanic
before you purchase it
pre-purchase inspection is what you want
to do it'll cost you you know 100 bucks
but man it's going to give you some
peace of mind
before you turn around and call me and
say i bought a 10 000 car that's a lemon
what do i do
so if i was in your shoes that's what
i'd be doing i don't think you're gonna
find an eight or nine thousand dollar
car at a reputable dealership you may be
able to get one through an auto broker
or wholesaler that can find you a good
deal on something reliable
but i would get something as cheap as
possible to get you from a to b get your
emergency fund saved up try to sell your
car for as much as you can get for it
and then eventually we upgrade once
we're in baby step four through six
okay no it sounds good i can definitely
go ahead and do that yeah the key here
is doing your research and being patient
and it may take another month or two
before you find that the right car but
don't do things out of desperation
here's how i like to look at it the
person with the most patience the most
information
always wins and the most options and so
when you only have two options
that sucks we need more options when
it's really urgent and you're really
desperate that sucks
when you have no patience that sucks so
take your time do a lot of research
online always get it inspected don't do
anything out of desperation always pay
cash try to negotiate and you'll be just
fine